today's a new day
just picked up from school
he says he has a surprise for me what is
that those aren't the glasses my reading
glasses from my nightstand
next to my bed please because i can't
see with those
i need to be able to see yes
i know but i can't see i need my special
glasses they're on the side of my bed
can you go get them please
thank you
he's about to go to jiu-jitsu and um my
vision's not that bad i have negative
1.5 1.25 negative 0.75 which is really
low
um it's probably what most of us would
see
that have 20 20 vision if your eyes are
a little bit tired like things just look
a little bit fuzzy so it's really easy
for me to forget that i'm not wearing my
contacts nor do i really need glasses
but it's not until the sun starts
setting or i'm driving that i just want
my vision to be extra
freaking sharp
so that's why he's getting that for me
but as you guys saw he's in his ghee
we're about to go to jiu jitsu um right
now he is on summer break so there's
this like weird gap
which one let me see
monkey i need my glasses please
i'll be right back but before i do that
um
yeah so there's this weird gap so he
gets to be here for like about an hour
to 40 minutes um
and he likes having a snack because we
always get snacks between or that in
between school to jiu-jitsu practice
but i've realized that when he has
snacks that are super high in sugar he
just is
bouncing off the walls and i never
really believed in that when i was
growing up because i'm like yeah
whatever i don't feel it but i'm also
not a really hyper kid um so i've opted
for something a little bit less sweet we
got some oreo like some korean version
of oreo cookies which is still kind of
on the sweeter side but not as sweet as
like candy got in pretzels which he
really likes
yeah
and
this one it's a baked banana bread
so he can have a little bit of the
sweetness but not too much where he's
bouncing off the jiu jitsu matte walls
so we'll see
yes
they're in a drawer cool that's not
where i wanted them from i kept seeing
the side of my bed
but those work
those work thank you so much you did me
a huge favor thank you for helping me
you ready to go
okay
come here these are the snacks that you
can eat right now
you can have
some korean oreo cookies
it is junk you're right but i'm trying
to be nice uh banana bread cookie or
pretzels what do you want
because you just had grapes of course
okay
well you did on the way there
and i have your water ready to go
so i want to say tyka's been doing jiu
jitsu now for maybe a year
monkey
you did so
good today
you were listening you didn't get in
trouble you were a leader
you were an excellent partner
how did you feel
good yeah why do you feel
good huh i don't know
are you proud of yourself yeah how come
you're proud of yourself
i love it you love it
yay
okay gotta fix that seat belt of yours
but i love that you love it you're doing
so good dude
it's dinner time now
you don't want dinner that means
you get to eat yummy food and get big
muscles
you can get dumplings
oh yeah let's eat some dumplings
and then we'll play with legos
hey do you want to call papa and tell
him that you did bad
yeah okay let's call papa
oh no
uh oh
oh no
he's not available
okay so we just got home and i think
pranking papa's gonna have to wait cuz
my dude ran out of batteries before we
got home
so on this diet one of the
requirements i was about to say
prerequisites but one of the
requirements is that we get 10 000 steps
in a day and right now i'm currently at
4
900 steps i think what i'm gonna do is
while tyka sleeps
and papa works i'm gonna walk around um
just a street right here just go up and
down the block
and uh i'll leave the doors open so if
and when tyka not when or not if what
the hell am i talking about but when
when
tycho wakes up
um he'll just get out and he can see me
right outside of the car
okay so i ended up walking a mile
outside while taika slept
um it is so damn hot right now it's a
106 outside and it's
6 00 p.m the sun's been setting really
late i want to say around 8 o'clock out
here and it's been so nice because you
feel like you have such a long day
speaking of long days
this guy's still sleeping he's had a
really
long day
i just picked them up
from the car put them here took off his
key because it was really hot you see
kind of his hair still sticking
to his face
took him out of it turned on the ac nice
and cold
he is out
like a light
but yeah i'm really happy that i didn't
waste time and i didn't wake him up and
i let him sleep i gave myself about um i
want to say like about 30 minutes just
to walk
it's one of my goals like i said to get
in 10 000 steps so
i figured it was a win-win situation i
really do try to set up my life in a way
where i can achieve as much as possible
i really try not to let myself and my
goals
down so i try to make it all work it's
not easy you guys but doing things like
creating systems creating a schedule
um having non-negotiables that's always
going to help so a schedule for me would
be
for example
monday
through wednesday
papa will wake up i mean we both wake up
but we get up and papa knows that it's
his day to get taika ready for school
give him breakfast drop him off at
school all while i'm training and then
um thursday friday or sometimes
wednesday depending on if he has jk news
days or not then we switch then i do the
morning routine
um and then you know things like that
right even things like making sure tyka
gets his his little vitamins i have one
of these for him i just make sure that
you know he's learning his days of the
week and then i make sure that he takes
this so then it becomes thoughtless and
one last thing i have to think about and
i try to take care of all of that on
sundays for example um i used to have a
family calendar here that just didn't
end up sticking but i even have a family
camera where i like i set up what events
and birthdays and you know where we're
gonna be
uh it's a family did i say family
calendar already well if i didn't it's
called the family calendar and we put
all of our agendas and schedules and
stuff on there taika has his practice
his school
anything he needs we all throw it on
there we're all very much aware of what
the month looks like so things like that
really do set you up for success another
thing i do is every sunday i know that
i'm going to do the laundry i know that
i'm going to clean up my fridge um
i know that i'm going to be going to the
grocery store these are the things that
you know i try to set up for myself
again for success and i highly recommend
you do the same for you too
okay
um so tyga still sleeping
so i'm gonna try to make
um
dinner as quietly as possible
in front of me i have some beef this
isn't the leanest cut of beef we could
find this one's in 93 7.
we usually like to do 96 4 if possible
i'm assuming papa couldn't find anything
leaner than this so we'll just have to
work with it um oh not 96 93 holy crap i
can't do math so i'm gonna make our
world famous that really wasn't famous
by us by someone else
um stanford dean's monster mash
and this is like our version of it we do
it
way lazier than how he does it um but
basically i'm gonna just put some garlic
powder
i'm not sure which one i want to use yet
but these are both garlic powder garlic
salt i have to see the macros on this i
feel like this might have fat in it
because
they seem fried but if they're not i'm
throwing these in there
some pepper
and that's kind of it i'll probably boil
um some veggies on the side for it
i shouldn't even call it monster mash i
should just call it ground beef
concoction because that's really what it
is because monster mash has all kinds of
good stuff like
bone broth beef bone broth
um i forgot what other [ __ ] it has and i
think it also uses bison which is way
leaner than beef
so
i'm making a beef concoction so it fits
my macros that's what i should say
but this guy right here
is using my fitness pal to figure out if
glued on this isn't even what is this
this one's
if noodles
fit
his macros and do they
use
had any carbs today because you were
just planning this no just because uh
just the day went by and i didn't really
have that much problems oh
damn so if you're also doing um
macros put up the asian market because
there's some
there's some dumplings that are
um
some
udon and noodles that are microfriendly
so don't sleep on the asian markets um
we did a whole ass video
on it on barbell brigade youtube channel
so check it out we just posted it i
think uh yeah this month in june so
check it out
in other news
damn that looks bomb it's a big old one
yeah
maybe you can just measure it afford it
or not
a whole thing
because
well show me the macros on what it is
half but
what i wanted to tell you
was taika did so good in jiu jitsu today
right yeah but every time he does good
in jiu jitsu you know what he wants me
to tell you
you did really he did really bad so we
facetimed you and you didn't answer it
did i even get it oh weird yeah i did
here i'll block you i'll give you some
of these no actually the lighting looks
really good
so
we were like set on first thing was
we're gonna come home let you know that
he did bad and um
he ended up knocking out and he's still
out he's still over there we have to use
pillows so we can cover the sunlight um
we could put the blinds down i don't
know why papa did this but
yeah this guy is out
taika
gonzos and it's like
6 44 right now i don't know if i should
wake him up i always feel bad
he doesn't get his little toddler naps
anymore because he's a kindergartner
according to him he's like
kindergarteners don't take naps
he's a kindergartner now yeah i said
that
he's about to be five in two months
where's the stop button on this excuse
me
five babe we've had this little monkey
for five years already is that crazy
bugs
that's crazy bones now
okay so i've opted for udon noodles as
well
i'm gonna make myself or i made myself a
little salad with some lemon
juice literally just got a lemon and
squeeze the juice into it what are you
doing over there
fine
uh and then through some
what are these called again
something but something tomatoes no but
there's a specific tomato
[Applause]
they're a little i don't think you're
whatever
i'm like farting out of my brain what
the hell are they called
they're just called little tomatoes but
i thought they were just something else
anyway
and then i have this bad boy that i'm
gonna
season in a little bit
and put you on to something really good
i'm just gonna cut it up and throw this
directly on it
two carbs whatever i can afford it
that
and then in my water i put this because
after a while you just get so tired of
drinking water and i'm not a big fan of
coke or like those zero ones so i get
this crystal light
um each little packet in here
if you can see it
is only five calories and i don't use
the whole packet because it's really
really sweet and
ironically enough even though i love
candy still too sweet for me so i don't
do it
i get like less than half i think i get
a quarter like one of these sticks is
like three
of those barbell brigade water bottles
that you saw here
like this
and it's so bomb
okay so i threw in some ponzu sauce and
show you the one i use initially i
didn't like this one i like the one that
you can find um do i have it anywhere
the one that they sell like at every
like american supermarket this one is
from a japanese supermarket and this one
is bom
only one gram or one carb so get this
it's very citrusy it's like
what can i compare it to it's like a
super light
it's not even like a soy sauce but like
citrusy soy sauce no right
would you compare ponzu to
yeah okay
i guess i nailed it and got the udon
season the beef with what i told you i
seasoned with and threw some in there
[Music]
let's see what papa's doing
he created a miso broth garlic miso
garlic miso
wow i'm trying to do it for the picture
so it looks good do it for the gram yeah
i've been like compiling a bunch of
pictures of all my food um to show like
that when you're not dieting it doesn't
have to be boring it's not going to suck
yeah it doesn't have to be garlic and
i mean god
what are you saying
that i need sleep i think is what i'm
releasing what i realized is what i'm
missing is some
good old-fashioned seafood
uh we have i'm gonna see
i'm so tired oh my
it's
god
if you have kids
you can relate to what just happened
okay let's see
so [ __ ] off now okay wait i have sea
weed
where let me see man
oh my god i think papa and i are about
to go on a date because like
he's still sleeping
and on purpose i put on
seeing in the background and kind of
loud so he can wake up to some like nice
tunes and he hasn't woken up yet so
guess papa and i
are on a [ __ ] date papa
don't make me regret my food don't make
me regret my food
oh i don't regret my food it's nasty
it's not nasty it's just not what i want
i like really subtle
yeah that's it
i know
the dude
just woke up
we're almost done with our meals
but
lucky for taika we have oh
his preferred meal
for tonight he actually wants to eat
dumplings
monkey
are you ready for some dumplings
okay i'll give you some time
it's gonna go down trust me
that's not good
what did we do because he was so bad he
was so bad papa i might get on the
camera
if we did banjo jitsu we got train at
home remember
why are you smiling
do you want
did really good today
he was so good he was listening doing
all the moves paying attention asking
questions answering questions he didn't
have to do push-ups he did all of that
it was awesome
good job again bro yeah bro
hey what hey are you kidding me this is
a dining table
down there you play play oh no no okay
i'm gonna put you down yeah you're going
fart quan and his cravings
gets some type of nara nada food to make
it fit but it grows it fits that's the
point it says
if you get the original flavor it's zero
fat i think only seven grams of carbs
and one gram of protein
so i have enough today
so i'm just down one more protein shake
and then i'll use that as what my
grandma would call
yep which means brush your mouth with a
different flavor you know got it
and what's cuny about yogurtland is
obviously they sell yogurt ice cream in
different flavors um and one of the
perks of it is that you can go into like
this buffet style bar that they have
and they have different toppings that
you can pick from so you can pick from
like
um
fresh fruit
candies crackers syrup sprinkles you
name it it's all there
and this is what tyka picked taika open
it up dude and tell the world tell the
world hold it
there you go
what did you pick dude give me the
breakdown i picked a banana
and what else i picked some of these in
them
so we have little lemon m's we got the m
m's with peanuts
man you like m m's don't you bother yeah
i got the the littlest the tiniest one
and then
and i heard you got some reese's
in there too
yeah eat it take the first bite i want
to live through you dude because i can't
eat that right
here here this is yours this is yours
okay
all right kiss it dude kiss it what else
are you gonna do yeah what butt are you
gonna get let's see let's see
okay cool
oh yeah that's a good buy oh
what does it taste like
and chocolate is it amazing
am i missing out
oh that looks so
good dude
[Applause]
that's what i want
it's so bomb
oh enjoy monkey i hope you enjoy it and
it dances on your tongue
okay okay okay here
oh that looks delicious
is it delicious
look at the little ice cream they turned
into
changing its melting
and now the boys are playing with legos
and watching
blade
there's way
huh vampire
okay i got it i got it i got it monkey
you're scaring me dude
that shouldn't hit you
the hulk no it really hit you
there's way more there's way too much
testosterone in this house
we need to make a girl this is some
[ __ ] i'm outnumbered here okay
there's grandpa papa and taika i don't
like it in this house anymore i'm
getting tired of it gotta make a girl
next
not dropping a pregnancy hint at all
and on that note
i'll bid you
farewell
good night thank you so much